may is national nurses month a time to
honor these special humans who have
dedicated their lives to helping other
people and in honor of national nurses
month we wanted to do a little something
special for a nurse who wanted some
beauty advice oh gosh do i love beauty
and all things beauty take a look
hi my name is catherine altieri and i'm
from staten island new york i'm an
intensive care nurse at staten island
university hospital i initially majored
in music and never really thought about
becoming a nurse but i was inspired by
my brother dan who is also a nurse at
the same hospital
i work 12-hour shifts four days a week
when i'm at work i'm a plain jane i wear
no makeup and i have my hair up in a bun
when i'm outside of work i go full glam
pink winged eyeliner shimmery eyeshadow
and false eyelashes my husband jokes
around with me that i either look like
i'm ready to walk the red carpet or like
i just rolled out of bed
drew can you help a nurse out i'd love
to learn to get an everyday look that's
natural quick and easy and doesn't take
too much time to do and makes me feel
beautiful inside and out of the hospital
i so
relate i really do i i think we all um a
lot of us uh live in extremes i feel
like i get very together for work and
then in real life it's a hot mess so boy
does this speak to me um and this
morning we worked with my friends at
maybelline along with their amazing
makeup artist jenna christina to show
catherine how to get that every day look
so let's check that out
hi ladies hi hi drew i am so excited to
be doing this with you jenna and
catherine i am thrilled so catherine
normally likes to do nothing or go all
the way so today we're going to scale
her back into a more natural makeover
something that's approachable to wear
every day catherine why do you think
that you're an extremist because i am
too i'm very all or nothing but why are
you like that you know what i feel like
it's almost like an alter ego nurse by
day rock star by night
that's really kind of me in a nutshell
i am a makeup junkie through and through
i always have been i grew up in a makeup
chair as a little girl and i watched
women transform and stand
more empowered and to me that's what
beauty is it's a feeling
and i'd love to know what you're
planning on doing today i'm going to do
a makeover on catherine using maybelline
new york's green edition it's high
performing makeup with a high percentage
of natural origin ingredients the
packaging is made with up to 95 recycled
material and the formulas are clean and
vegan we all have our eyes open to how
important being eco and green and planet
friendly
so i applaud maybelline for this line
this is really beautiful i'm going back
in with the lighter shade right under
your eyes to brighten it up if you put
one shade all over your face then you're
just flattening it so there's no depth
or dimension exactly a little
highlighter a little contour
a little something lighter under the
eyes a little something darker on the
jawline because i lost my jawline a few
years ago it just took off oh my god i
hope you find her one day i don't think
so i think she went on permanent
vacation
okay so next it's buildable volume so if
you want a natural look you can put one
coat on if you want a little bit more
volume you can just add a couple more
this is really nice because it has mango
oil in it it has lasting hydration your
lips are going to feel and look really
smooth and i really need this because
i'm just in a mask all day and i'm
super dry all the time
so we're gonna do a big reveal on the
stage i'm so excited to do that with you
guys katherine are you feeling good
about that yes and my hair is not going
to be in a bun for once you're going to
style it and come out full force i'm
going to actually
literally let my hair down and
figuratively i am going to be out there
waiting for you ready to embrace you and
show you off and jenna i'm so excited to
see what you're going to do with this
extraordinary line i can't wait to see
everything
[Music]
you